there is a very small amount of gold in
the sea dissolved in seawater in
absolute amount it's a huge amount
because there are tens of thousands of
square of cubic kilometers of seawater
but the concentration is quite low after
the First World War the German nation
was nearly bankrupt and Fritz Harbor the
inventor of the harbour process for
making ammonia out of nitrogen wanted to
devise a process for getting gold out of
seawater to make Germany rich again and
so he tried some experiments in his lab
great secrecy because he didn't want
people to discover that he was doing
this using synthetic seawater his lab
was in Berlin a long way from the seas
so they made seawater out of salt and
water and it worked really well
his process I've forgotten the details
of how he got it out so secretly they
built the equipment into a ship and they
went into the sea and tried to get gold
out of the seawater but it didn't work
and eventually they discovered the
reason it didn't work was the salt that
they were used for their synthetic
seawater had more gold in it than the
real sea water and so although the
chemistry was okay there just isn't
enough gold in seawater to make it
worthwhile this is gold
okay gold in water now normally
everybody equates the color of gold with
there's my wedding ring
that's what gold looks like how is it
red why is it red it's this is this is
remarkable and the key difference
between the gold here is this bulk gold
and this is that the gold in here is in
the form of nanoparticles which are
about six nanometers across in this case
now nanotechnology is seen as this
wonderful new type of technology
cutting-edge really state-of-the-art and
aspects of it are interestingly the
chemistry involved in preparing these
buried in you back in
a number centuries ago and the key idea
here is that what you have here are
these small chunks of gold and you keep
them separated because if you just put
gold you put neutral gold in there what
will happen it's all clumped back
together in your lender but something
that looks like this so what you do is
you enduring the chemical synthesis you
actually put a charge on the particles
and that keeps them apart why are they
red guess the first question is why is
my wedding ring gold why is gold gold
why does it have that color and the key
thing here is that they we've got to
think about how the electrons behave
once we get a handle on how electrons
behave we understand the optical
properties we understand the magnetic
properties we of course understand the
electronic and electrical transport
properties but the reason my ring is
gold is how electromagnetic waves how
light interacts with the electrons in
this in in bold gold and what's what's
key or one of the things that's key this
doesn't quite grasp all the ice but one
of the things that's key is the idea of
an oscillation of those electrons and
that oscillation is called a plasma and
so the electrons will move back and
forth at a particular preferred
frequency and so when the frequency of
light coming in matches that particular
preferred sloshing frequency of the
electrons the thing we call a clasp on
you you you get a unenhanced absorption
and that's why you get a particular
color now if you take your gold and
instead of it being a big chunk of gold
like this you make it smaller and
smaller and smaller then those electrons
first of all those fewer of them and
moreover they are so laid back and forth
at a different rate simply because
they're in a in a small smaller volume
and you consume that rate at which the
oscillate back thought simply by
changing the size and so the difference
here the key difference is that you've
got smaller particles the electron
sloshed back and forth at a different
rate and so they appear red rather than
gold and that really I guess that's one
of the grow Li Grails of nanoscience in
that simply by changing the size you
change the properties electron from so
one of the things that many research
groups are driving towards us to sort of
have an artificial periodic table of the
elements when instead of going hydrogen
helium lithium what you have is you
control how the electrons behave in
these structures simply by changing the
size so you could build up in essence
an entire period artificial periodic
table just on the basis of goals simply
by changing its size and shape